[Musique]
raconte moi quand tu étais au t2 gennady
quand on rentre de vacances
le plu va mieux c'est de vider les
balises avec bérénice tu vas voir ça
fait des mois que le revenu des partis
en vacances et moi en attendant vous
faites des bâtons des bateaux des
bateaux est même pas où ma mère si tu
che à titus j'ai une bonne nouvelle pour
toi
bérénice est de retour
je veux absolument certain je les ai
aperçus à l'autre bout du palais où mon
cas pour vivre heureux
les vagues ont vu ni témoin envers ces
bateaux il faut que tout soit propre les
daubes est revenu eh bien tu suis la
voix si british
[Musique]
votre mur dany mon titus cher mode car
je suis bien contente de vous revoir et
nos échecs ou et en banlieue
six décennies pakistan où les américains
à ça fait plaisir de rentrer chez soi
même si c'est chez le grand jacques à
toute épreuve que tu n en place et donc
de rémy ça me sens bien remplie samoa où
sont-ils les dépositaires ici paris ce
qui veut dire garder son merveilleux je
me demande où fait rage et tout ça voilà
on regarde devant lui le monde ko le dos
rond
j'espère que je chante lui dire tu 2 3 4
5 6 7 et 8 c'est bien ça tout est là
merci mosca à bientôt bientôt du monde
remise je partais avec une banlieue de
tours vient de but
je n'avais rien à m alors je me suis
fait faire quelques nouvelles rap on va
tous les ranger tout ne peut pas mettre
des balises dans fortis
j'ai passé que tu pourrais emprunter un
grand coffre au grand yaka ça nous ont
pas non non non non non les coffres de
grands garçons 12 plein et puis ils ont
gardé par ceci et cela
ces bobos bible que tu t'es pas gentils
nous tenir parole
une bonne idée il ya l'armoire tu fais
c'est évident mais ouverte ictus c'était
remarque une serpillière sur vais
demander la clé amène quand ils rentrent
de vacances de ma tin oo du tube i 3 4 5
6 7 8
parce que l'on n'est pas oublié mais en
incluant un plaisir de vous revoir
le joie à mon jeune ami si tu voyais
tout ce que je rapporte au rang de
merveilles incomplet nos valises au
pleine bourre et des blancs dans
d'objets extra ordinaire oil vous
renvoie souvent à balai dont l'armoire
ses bienfaits tous ces biens l'armoire
vide tu la connais a voulu prendre la
clé est allé ouvrir l'armoire des
merveilles la prends tu verras tu es
tous
je n'attendais tour sensationnel alors
le premier cas il faut pas les mettre
dans l'armoire pourquoi donc tous cette
armoire est pleine de microbes on débute
au haut débit thd dans l'armoire on
avait les mythes donc ça nous ont tous
fait des trous partout c'est bien connu
bon alors c'est rageant bijoux je sais
ce qu'ils te vantes habile et la petite
merveille
or à votre place on dirait demandé un
grand coffre aux grands cabas aux agro
chauffe eau sale bundle je leur ai
trahis si ce sera très pratique et très
décoratif
je vais le demander aux grandes gueules
ce poids people meet des armoires et
l'athlète a même l'avoir demandée et
après
c'est notre histoire
à
[Applaudissements]